les quatre personnes qui étaient gardés
à vue hier soir dans le cadre de l'
enquête sur l'assassinât du petit
grégory ces quatre personnes ont été
libérées la nuit dernière et apparemment
l'enquète doit maintenant repartir à
zéro 6 à belvès hier soir la garde à vue
longue de six heures de la famille au
lard quatre parents éloignés des
villemin n'a rien donné
découragé les gendarmes renonçait vers 2
heures du matin complètement terminée
veulent communiquer de recommencer à
zéro cela signifie repartir en quête de
témoignages sur le portrait robot de
l'assassin présumé un homme d'un mètre
quatre-vingt cheveux bruns et boucler la
quarantaine
mais ce visage ne dit rien non plus à
chantal au lard un des témoins de la
veille je connais pas jacuzzi ou
journalistiques alors je connais pas ce
robot qui n'avait pas eu l'idée il a des
idées les gendarmes on cherche aussi
d'arrache-pied sur le terrain cet après
midi ils ont repris à la minute près
l'emploi du temps de christine la mère
de grégory pour définir avec encore plus
de précision l'heure exacte à laquelle
elle est rentrée avec l'enfant
chronomètre en main
les gendarmes ont refait le parcours du
village à la maison des vim
ils ont ensuite passé le reste de
l'après midi enfermé avec jean marie et
christine dans la maison à lépanges tout
le monde attend impatiemment du nouveau
mais les gendarmes restent muets